- We currently understand very
little about the human brain.
Do you also hope that
the work at Neuralink
will help us understand
more about the human mind,
about the brain?
- Yeah, I think the work at
Neuralink will definitely shed
a lot of insight into how
the brain, the mind, works.
Right now, just the data we have
regarding how the brain
works is very limited.
We've got FMRI,
which is, that's kind of
like putting a stethoscope
on the outside of a factory wall,
and then putting it all
over the factory wall,
and you can sort of hear the sounds,
but you don't know what the
machines are doing, really.
It's hard, you can infer a few things,
but it's very broad brushstroke.
In order to really know
what's going on in the brain,
you have to have high-precision sensors
and then you want to have
stimulus and response.
Like if you trigger it, you
wonder, how do you feel?
What do you see?
How does it change your
perception of the world?
- You're speaking to physically?
Just getting close to the
brain, being able to measure
signals from the brain--
- Yeah.
- Will give us, sort of open
the door inside the factory?
- Yes, exactly.
Being able to have high-precision sensors
that tell you what
individual neurons are doing,
and then being able to trigger the neuron
and see what the response is in the brain,
so you can see the consequences of,
if you fire this neuron, what happens?
How do you feel, what does it change?
It'll be really profound
to have this in people,
because people can
articulate their change,
like if there's a change in mood.
Or they can tell you
if they can see better,
or hear better, or be
able to form sentences
better or worse, or their
memories are jogged,
or that kind of thing.